as populations have aged dementia has
soared to become the fifth leading cause
of death worldwide Alzheimer's disease a
form of dementia accounts for most of
these cases tens of billions of dollars
have been spent on Alzheimer's research
over the past several decades but still
there is no cure
all attempts to halt the progression of
the disease have failed now many major
drug companies have pulled out of
research altogether so why is
Alzheimer's disease still such a medical
mystery
one of the signs of Alzheimer's in the
brain is damage of connections and the
loss of large numbers of neurons over
time it affects the hippocampus and it's
connected structures making it harder to
form new memories or learn new
information as damage spreads through
the brain the cortex becomes thinner and
more memories are lost
although emotional responses can often
remain as the brain shrinks further it
slowly alters personality and behavior
and eventually the ability to live and
function independently
for 35 years there's been scientific
disagreement about the origins of the
disease the main area of debate has
focused on the abnormal buildup of
clumps of protein called amyloid plaques
often found in brains of those affected
by Alzheimer's but all attempts to
target this protein with drugs have
failed
a new study is now challenging the way
science thinks about the disease the
study suggests that the bacterium
Porfiry - gingivalis which is involved
in gum disease and may contribute to
Alzheimer's in studies on mice the
bacterium can cause brain inflammation
neural damage and amyloid plaques the
researchers went on to show in mice this
damage could be stopped using drugs that
target the toxic enzymes there's more to
this story though the risk of
Alzheimer's is higher in those who have
severe head injuries and also for those
with an arterial disease known as
atherosclerosis this suggests there are
many causes with one endpoint and
scientists hope that finding an
underlying cause that could tie these
together will hold the key to better
treatments in the future coming up next
how to defeat malaria